hi guys in this video we're going to
talk about how to lose the cellulite
okay the stuff that's on the side of
your hip and your butt the stuff that
you hate let's just talk about what is
this thing cellulite first normally you
have the skin you have this outer
connective kind of like a sheath of
connective tissue it's called fossa
right underneath the skin that keeps
everything held together it's like saran
wrap and then you have a fat layer okay
these little fat cells underneath and
then you have the muscle so you have
these layers what happens in satellite
is you have an enlargement of the fat
cells the fat cells get bigger they fill
up with fat then you can over stretch
facha
so this spiderweb thing is supposed to
hold it starts to separate in the fat
kind of bulges up through it giving this
dimple effect okay then behind it you
have atrophied muscle which makes the
whole thing kind of jiggly and hang off
the body so with the combination of
atrophied muscle fat cell enlargement
and broken-down fascia that's what's
happening so now let's talk about how to
reverse this thing because there are
things that you can do like if you had a
pregnancy and you basically gained a lot
of weight and then lost a lot of weight
and then you wanted to diet and gain a
lot of weight and lost on the way you're
eventually gonna get cellulite because
you're just you're you're creating in
this this this over stretching of your
fossa and that can do it as well but
typically what happens during menopause
is these hormone shift you're maybe more
inactive and everything just starts
going downhill so number one we want to
shrink the fat cell we need to get the
fat out when you lose weight when you
lose fat you're not getting rid of the
fat cell okay you're just shrinking them
you can't get rid of your fat cell
you're just making them smaller so to do
that you have to deal with the main
hormone that controls how much fat goes
in there and that's insulin you have to
lower insulin you cannot fix cellulite
without lowering insulin first okay how
do you lower insulin I'll put a link
down below but typically you're gonna
have to change the eating plan you have
to cut out the carbs are gonna have to
do
fasting so I listed exactly what you
need to do you need to watch that video
that will decrease this fat for sure
okay because because this is bigger this
fat is also producing inflammation too
so it's probably very very sore in your
hips and thighs as well but once you
reduce that the soreness will go away so
we want to lower insulin number two we
want to tighten up this facha this facha
is controlled by hormones specifically
growth hormone growth hormone is the
anti-aging hormone that is involved with
all proteins in the body not just the
hair skin nails but the facha around
your hips your buttocks and around that
fat if you try to lose weight unhealthy
you never fix the growth hormone factor
and you end up never getting rid of the
site light so we want this is all this
is about really getting the liver
healthy it's about triggering growth
home as much as you can it's not about
taking hormones it's about you have to
do some type of exercise you have to
there's no way around it you have to
physically move those muscles in there
to activate it but the best is a
combination of a little higher intense
full-body exercise specifically you know
in the hips and thighs but then lots of
rest the key is recovery and sleep so we
want to increase the sleep increase the
high intensity lots of rest make sure
you don't over train and then you can
get these this fashion back and the
muscle as well moderate amount of
protein you want to consume high quality
amino acids I like eggs egg yolk don't
do low fat protein powders you want to
add more fat if you do a protein powder
add fat to it in a minute fasting vital
because in a minute fasting triggers
growth hormone if you're doing five six
meals a day spread out or snacks you're
never going to increase growth hormone
and then the third thing is cortisol
cortisol is very destructive on the
muscles so more cortisol from stress
will just prevent everything from
working
it keeps the insulin high it keeps
growth from wound down so we really want
to handle with this this you may want to
support the adrenals directly if you
need to have because the jury knows
control cortisol but typically what you
to do is you have to cut the stress out
increase the sleep very vital and then
also vitamin D I get get son if you can
more son it would be better and a lot of
walking walking will also lower cortisol
so the combination and the days off that
you don't do the high-intensity go for a
walk very important and then the last
thing is estrogen estrogen if you ever
notice more women get cellulite than men
because of the estrogen component
estrogen makes fat unfortunately
estrogen puts the fat around the hips so
what how do you lower estrogen you you
want to consume cruciferous vegetables
you want to get your liver really really
healthy very very important to do that
but the last thing I want to mention is
that this condition is not a little
thing
it's a major problem that's been there
chronically for it takes so many years
for this to end up like this so just
realize it's gonna take some time to get
this back it could take one to two to
three years before you start getting
your your tissues back to where they
should don't think it's gonna happen in
a week and give up just think long term
because to rebuild this stuff at if you
especially if you're menopausal it's
just gonna have time but you're gonna
see changes over time so and you'll see
improvements and definitely do it before
and after pictures so you can visualize
that so you're not looking yourself in
the mirror every second and not seeing
the it changes as fast alright go ahead
and apply these things and put your
comments below forget it forget it I'm
done
press the subscribe button and I will
keep you updated on the future of events